alors l'acide hyaluronique c'est quoi
faut déjà comprendre que c'est ce fameux
acide dont tout le monde parle mais dont
on ne sait plus forcément ce que c'est
vrai tout le monde en parle alors c'est
un produit utilisé en injection pour
faire gonfler les lèvres ou autre chose
et réduire les rides donc en fait
comment ça se passe
chimiquement c'est à dire que les rides
quoi comment quand on injecte ça les
rides quoi en fait c'est un gel un
produit de comblement c'est une forme de
gel donc en fait ça
vient combler les rides ou ça vient
restaurer les volumes par exemple
puisque après une perte de poids ou ou
avec le temps qui passe tout simplement
on perd du volume en particulier au
niveau de du milieu du visage voilà donc
on peut restaurer des volumes comme ça
alors à la base c'est une molécule
naturellement présente dans notre corps
comme vous l'avez dit au niveau de la
peau c'est cette molécule qui permet
d'hydrater notre peau et plus le temps
passe moins le corps produit cette
molécule donc c'est pour ça que les
rides s'accumulent ça on vous explique
donc on vous en réinjecte c'est aussi
simple que ça alors on est avec Sarah et
vous allez voir d'autres images dans un
instant Sarah vous avez participé à la
première saison d'ultimatum France sur
Netflix c'est via cette émission que le
grand public vous a connu aujourd'hui si
vous êtes avec nous c'est pour parler de
vos injections d'acide hyaluronique vous
avez fait quoi comme injection vous ou
alors en fait moi j'ai fait un full face
c'est à dire que j'ai fait plusieurs
parties du visage d'accord j'ai fait le
nez les pommettes les lèvres et le
menton et aussi le la jawling en fait
d'accord vous avez vous avez fait la
totale pourquoi pourquoi qu'est-ce qui
vous a chauffé à le faire je pense que
j'avais un manque de confiance en moi dû
à certains traumatismes d'enfance parce
que j'ai été victime d'harcèlement
scolaire et voilà j'avais pas du tout
confiance en moi et je pense que ça n'a
pas arrangé je me suis beaucoup retrouvé
dans les réseaux sociaux ça a été un
refuge pour moi mais je pense aussi que
ça a joué en fait au niveau des filtres
vous voyez la même tête que sur vos
filtres
je voulais oui je voulais je voulais
plus ressembler parce que je pensais que
pendant l'émission j'allais être plus
jolie en fait avec les filtres voilà
donc vous avez dit moi je vais être
comme les filtres un petit peu
c'est vrai que les filtres voilà ça joue
maintenant alors les filtres avec la
nouvelle loi il y aura toujours des
filtres
exactement j'ai déjà pas mal alors non
mais c'est vrai alors vous effectuez
donc des recherches sur Internet et vous
trouvez la praticienne qui vous fera aux
injections c'est ça vous dites voilà
comment vous en avez entendu parler
c'est vous donc copines qui vont alors
j'ai cherché tout simplement sur les
réseaux sociaux donc Instagram et j'ai
trouvé cette praticienne mais comment
vous avez entendu parler de l'acide
hyaluronique c'est vos copines qui le
faisaient ou pas du tout sur les réseaux
sociaux en vrai c'est banalisé en fait
voilà moi j'ai vu ça directement et donc
vous avez été sur internet et vous avez
trouvé une praticienne c'est ça qui va
vous faire vos injections c'est ça et du
coup elle avait un nombre d'abonnés
assez important il y a quand même 3 elle
avait quand même énormément de photos
avant après voilà il y avait pas mal de
choses même si je sais que c'est pas une
raison forcément pour y aller mais voilà
moi ça m'a rassuré en fait dans mon
choix
c'est quelqu'un qui a 300000 voilà
followers tout ça mais beaucoup de
photos vous êtes renseigné auprès de
peut-être de personnes qui avaient été
déjà été ou pas du tout pas du tout
parce qu'en fait cette personne là elle
était basée en Angleterre d'accord donc
vous êtes déplacé en Angleterre non elle
est venue sur Paris en fait elle faisait
des comme des enfin je sais pas comment
on appelle ça mais voilà des sessions
sur Paris aux États-Unis etc oui
d'accord et donc là vous avez pris
rendez-vous avec elle c'est ça au bouton
vous a donné rendez-vous assez
rapidement ce qu'elle n'est sur Paris je
crois que c'était une même pas une
semaine après donc voilà ça a été assez
rapide voilà alors au début vous vouliez
seulement faire des injections sur le
nez et la bouche ouais c'est ça et
comment que vous savez que vous avez
tout fait mais en fait quand je suis
arrivé ce qui est marrant c'est que
quand elle m'a vu
elle-même elle était un peu perdue elle
savait pas trop ce qu'elle devait faire
sur moi donc je lui ai dit le nez la
bouche et au final je pense que voilà
c'était quand même assez un prix assez
conséquent donc elle s'est dit bon bah
si tu veux faire ça ça 800 euros 800
euros ça dure combien de temps
environ un an logiquement
si tu veux je peux te faire les
pommettes et la mâchoire le package
j'ai 27 ans
vous avez été tout de suite déçu en
sortant dès que vous avez fait votre
tête ça dit quoi bah en fait au départ
dès que j'ai vu ma tête je me suis dit
ok ça change mais ça va encore mais
c'est vrai que
vers le soir même le lendemain matin je
me suis regardé je me suis dit mais
c'est pas possible c'est une catastrophe
partout enfin même voilà là on voit dans
le tournage c'est horrible momenton il
est pointu mais pour mettre elles sont
hyper ressorties sachant que j'ai déjà
les pommettes qui sont tracées voilà
c'est ça exactement et la lèvre moi je
sais qu'on m'a injecté beaucoup c'est ce
que m'a dit le médecin qui m'a enlevé
après à peu près 4 5 4000 litres donc
c'est énorme alors donc vous voyez et là
c'est quoi c'est
quand vos potes vous voient vos copines
ce samedi soir pourquoi tu as fait ça
se voyait grave ça se voyait totalement
vous étiez gonflé de partout
vous n'êtes pas la même et vous faites
beaucoup plus âgés ici que maintenant
c'est incroyable
donc rapidement vous êtes rendu compte
que l'acide hyaluronique que vous avez
un qui vous avez injecté qu'elle vous
avait injecté ne vous convenait pas du
tout pourquoi alors c'est possible ça
docteur voilà qui a des acides
hyaluronique qui peuvent convenir à
certaines personnes et nous à d'autres
en fait elle a peut-être utilisé un
acide hyaluronique qui n'était pas
adapté pour le pour les lèvres par
exemple il y a différents types d'acides
ironique par exemple moi je travaille
avec une gamme où il y a peut-être une
vingtaine d'acide hyaluronique rien que
pour le visage donc c'est en fait c'est
on peut faire du sur mesure mais si on
prend un acide hyaluronique très compact
ou ce qu'on appelle très réticulé et
qu'on l'ajecte là où il faut pas ça peut
donner des nodules et surtout dans votre
histoire ce qui m'a interpellé c'est 4
millilitres dans une lèvre c'est
monstrueux comme quand
ça fait 15 ans que je pratique les
injections d'acide hyaluronique j'ai
jamais injecté 4000 litres d'un coup
dans une lèvre si on fait dans
l'écrasante majorité des cas on injecte
une seringue pour les deux
mais ça fait combien de secondes
alors justement vous voyez votre votre
côté là
on se dit
ça parce qu'elle est très sympathique à
ça c'est vrai que et franchement non
mais c'est donc là vous êtes à droite
vous devez être au bout de votre vie
vous êtes touché ouais ah ouais j'étais
je me regardais plus dans la glace quand
je voulais plus sortir je voulais plus
faire de photos je veux plus en faire
donc est-ce que vous avez appelé la
chirurgienne j'ai essayé de la contacter
alors je l'ai contacté justement mais
voilà elle parle en anglais je suis pas
bilingue non plus enfin je pense que le
fait qu'elle soit loin que ce soit juste
bien Instagram ça a été compliqué en
fait elle a pas forcément un petit peu
quoi au cas où vous a dit non non c'est
pas grave c'est résorbé voilà alors
comment on fait parce que vous voulez
tout enlever non tout enlever ouais
c'est ça et en fait c'était juste avant
le tournage donc j'avais très peu de
temps et j'ai été voir du coup un vrai
professionnel cette fois-ci qui vous l'a
donné alors j'ai trouvé sur doctolib
d'accord que voilà c'était sûr et du
coup même lui était extrêmement choquée
de voir mon visage il m'a même dit qu'on
m'avait mis peut-être de l'acide pour
les hommes au niveau de ouais c'est de
la cible en fait qui est compact c'est à
dire que quand je touchais mon visage
c'était dur c'était hyper dur et ça me
choquait ça me faisait super peur
d'ailleurs et voilà du coup j'ai été
voir cette personne là directement
d'accord est-ce qu'il a pu revenir en
arrière très vite ou bien ce que c'est
impossible alors oui sauf que enfin ça a
été sur plusieurs séances ça n'a pas été
en une seule séance parce que j'en avais
énormément et comme on fait pour en fait
il y a on peut injecter un produit qui
s'appelle la hyaluronidas qui est
l'antidote de l'acide hyaluronique alors
quand il y a un excès d'injection on
peut injecter cet hyaluronidas pour
dissoudre le produit le problème qu'on
rencontre des injections illégales c'est
qu'on n'a pas la traçabilité du produit
c'est à dire qu'on sait même pas si
c'est de l'acide hyaluronique et qui a
été injecté bon là il y a eu de
laurentidas qui a été injecté ça a
marché mais le problème c'est que
souvent on peut même pas injecter
l'antidote et surtout ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que s'il y a une
complication grave de type injection
dans un vaisseau on a 6 heures pour
réagir donc déjà il y a un problème si
la personne elle est un jour à Paris un
jour à Madrid un jour à Londres un jour
à Dubaï ça va pas un autre jour à
Limoges
donc il vous a fait en plusieurs fois il
vous enlevé tout tout ses conneries j'ai
fait une fois avant le tournage et après
je pouvais pas le refaire donc
comme ça voilà exactement
j'ai dû avoir au cours quatre ou cinq
fois à peu près où il y a eu une date
alors ça vous a coûté cher de faire
enlever
mettre et remettre c'est traumatisme
c'était vous difficile de vous voir à
l'écran avec cette t très difficile
vraiment très très difficile quoi
franchement je me suis dit mais c'est
quoi cette question votre famille
ils ont essayé de me rassurer en fait
au bout de combien de temps vous êtes
revenus à la normale
ça fait pas très longtemps donc je
dirais à peu près un an quand même ah
non ça a mis parce que faut attendre
entre chaque aussi intervention donc
voilà et vu que j'en ai plusieurs ça
c'est un peu d'aller quoi